John: Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
I'm going to try an experiment today.
I have to make a video today, what should
I make it about?
Henry: A velociraptor!
John: Velociraptors?
I'm into it.
Okay, the velociraptor.
So, the velociraptor was not a famous dinosaur
until Michael Crichton's 1990 novel Jurassic
Park.
In that book, and the subsequent Steven Spielberg
movie, a velociraptor skeleton is excavated
in Montana, and there are these, like, terrifying
creatures.
They're smart and almost people-sized, and
they've got those weird reptilian scales and
they hunt in packs taking down dinos and people
alike.
And even if you haven't seen Jurassic Park,
and God knows Henry hasn't, you're still familiar
with, like, the terror of the velociraptor,
right?
Like, Toronto named its NBA team after the
raptors, because they're just... ohh, you
wanna stay away from them, they're gonna beat
you at basketball!
Yeah, except 1) The velociraptor never actually
lived in Montana, it lived in Mongolia in
China, 2) Velociraptors were not scaly, they
were feathered, 3) They probably didn't hunt
in packs, 4) They could not have hung out
in Jurassic Park, because they lived 75 million
years ago, in the Late Cretaceous Period,
and 5) They were not human-sized killing machines,
they were, like, long-tailed turkeys.
In short, Hank, the Toronto Raptors are named
after a Mongolian creature that probably looked
like this.
Adult velociraptors weighed less than the
average three-year-old human, and although
their name means "swift thief", in fact they
were probably quite slow, because they were
walking on short little turkey legs.
Ohh, off-topic, but at the State Fair turkey
legs are just so delicious; I wonder if velociraptor
legs are good...
You may have noticed that in real life, there
is one animal species that's truly terrifying,
and it's us.
We would have posed a far greater threat to
velociraptors than they would have posed to
us.
Anyway, the velociraptors in Jurassic Park
are based off of a larger American cousin
called deinonychus.
But they called them velociraptors because
that's a much cooler name, Hank!
And that actually happens a lot in the world
of dinousaurs.
Like, Hank, when we were kids, the coolest
dinosaur in the world was the brontosaurus,
which means "thunder lizard".
But Hank, it turns out that brontosaurus isn't
even a thing, it's just an apatosaurus, which
means "deceptive lizard", which isn't nearly
as cool.
I don't want my gigantic lizards to bring
the lies, I want them to bring the thunder.
Also, as Henry will happily point out to you,
apatosaurus isn't even that big, certainly
not compared to diplodocus.
So why did velociraptors have feathers?
Well, they were part of the bird-like Dromaeosaurid
family, all of which had feathers, and some
of which could probably actually fly.
But velociraptors couldn't fly, and they may
have used their feathers to, like, attract
mates, but probably it's just an evolutionary
left-over, the way that Blind Mole-rats still
have eyes and Humpback Whales have vestigial
hind legs.
But now that I've disappointed you by telling
you the truth about velociraptors I'm gonna
tell you two awesome things about them.
First, they could jump, like, ten feet high,
vertical.
Secondly, they had these retractable sickle-shaped
claws in their hind legs that they used to,
like, stab their prey.
And we know they could kill the somewhat larger,
although not as large as you would expect,
protoceratops.
We know this partly because there's a fossil
of a velociraptor and a protoceratops locked
in combat.
And then while they were fighting a sandstorm
came and drowned them in sand.
Hank, the pleasure of having a dinosaur-obsessed
child is that you realize both how much we
know and how much we don't know about the
distant past of life on Earth.
Like, Hank, the reason that Micheal Criton's
velociraptors were featherless is that we
didn't know for sure until 2007 that velociraptors
were feathered because that's when scientists
discovered quill knobs on one of their forearms.
There are a lot of cool things about dinosaurs,
Hank, but the coolest thing is that 100 million
years later we're still learning.
Thanks to Henry for the video topic.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.